you know
a little bit hello everyone welcome to
rational science the only site on the
internet that does physics rationally
everybody else moves Concepts around
anyways we have a great day today
and I'm going to be looking at
predictions today and specifically the
topic of today is steady state what is a
steady state Theory Universe Etc
but uh talking about predictions here's
a prediction for our extension series
our Extinction segment okay this is uh
these are a couple of news headlines
that came out the other day
one of them says God have mercy on all
of us Robert Kiyosaki warned that the
economy is the biggest bubble in history
and urged investors to dump paper assets
says the worst could be yet to come
according to Rich Dad and put that
author hold on to your money says Jeff
Bezos and say you may want to rethink
you know buying a new automobile
refrigerator or whatever Raul Paul says
AI could be the biggest bubble of all
time
and there you see that says AI will
usher in a global deflationary shock one
of the largest the world has ever seen
might be even bigger than the magnitude
that the um what is it then China
joining the World Trade Organization
ushering an era of cheap imported goods
for Americans
and then you have uh experts forecast
that AI will replace many workers while
lowering the cost of goods and services
for consumers
okay so uh the uh prognostic it doesn't
look too great you know out there you
may want to think about your
expenditures but above all keep in mind
that you know a lot of these
uh folks are talking about the upcoming
crash of some kind and you may not want
to believe it but I mean here's here all
the experts are pointing you in the same
direction
so uh it's up to you and the other issue
that you might want to think about is
uh how far away in time you know all
these events are supposed to happen
and uh here's another bit of news uh
that I've been covering lately and
that's got to do with the Yuan uh
currency that China has this bit of news
came out of Barons this week it says
since the early days of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine it's been clear that
the choice to weaponize the US dollar
would have consequences and by that they
mean you know consequences in Reverse
like consequences for the U.S sanctions
on Russia's access to U.S currency are
Paving the way for the ascent of the
Yuan China's currency as an alternative
for clearance settlement and Reserves at
least for countries willing to upset the
U.S this has been a gift from heaven for
China's leader Xi Jinping
and so yeah uh that's another thing
that's going on in the world uh whether
the Yuan will have the importance that
the dollar has today out there well you
know we we gotta wait and see uh what
happens with that but remember at one
point in time there was the dollar was
not the world currency as it is today
and so things change and if a lot of
countries go with China because they
believe the United States is weaponizing
the dollar
well that might change uh the I'll call
it the balance of influence in the world
okay balance of power Etc
okay uh here's uh uh an issue related to
our species
do you want to live you know 500 years
or do you want to live forever I mean
would that be great well I've discussed
in the past that living forever is not a
great deal you know the one thing God
envies in man is his mortality but here
uh the uh note that came out in
Scientific American says what a body
built to last a hundred years would look
like we would look a lot different if
evolution had designed the human body to
work well for a century or more okay it
says the process of human evolution has
resulted in bodies that are optimized
for successful reproduction and child
rearing but are not necessarily designed
for a healthy long lives medical
problems associated with aging are often
described as diseases that are our own
fault but is unfair to blame people for
inheritance inheriting bodies that were
not designed for extended use we can
shorten our lives but not prolong them
indefinitely
and says if humans were built primarily
for longevity and Perpetual Health or
anatomies and even our bodies molecular
processes would look very different than
they currently do the single-minded
pursuit of Life Extension could actually
be harmful to our species long-term
survival
you know so they have you know the
living forever or living for a long time
has been one of the uh key goals of many
individuals people wonder why we have to
die and assuming we have to Die Why
Can't We Live you know 200 500 A
Thousand Years
and the question is whether we would
want to
uh that's when I think it's a valid
issue imagine living 500 years so you
live through many generations of humans
you know you would see many things
happening
uh I don't know if you would tolerate
those changes you know I can barely
tolerate some of the changes going on
today so I can't imagine living 500
years
uh and seeing many many more changes and
then the other issue is whether it is
even possible
we're we're kind of like at the limit
some people live over 100 years you know
in the world
um
are we ever going to live 200 years and
my answer to that is no I don't think we
will I don't think anybody would want to
at some point I think you do want to die
and the question is whether the species
should die as well should the species
desire to die as a species should we
live forever as a species you know and
the question you got to answer is what
for if you could answer that question
you get the a cigar okay
okay here's a follower he says the
following says uh there will be pockets
of humanity around even if every nuke
were pushed you know and uh so the
question is you know uh we we discussed
the possibility that they start pressing
the buttons and red buttons and all you
need to do is press one of them and I
think it's over because everybody will
just start pressing buttons just in case
the other guy does you want to do it
first right and so you kind of have this
uh
you know the first guy who shoots the
the bullets gets the first hit he who
hits uh first hits twice so to speak you
know and so yeah
um I think that all we have to do is
press one button and you know will we
ever push that red button
if we do if someone does for whatever
reasons I think we will shoot a lot of
these nuclear weapons out there
a lot of them will just be used to you
know kill other weapons that are coming
in our way you know in our Direction
that's one possibility another one is
that a lot of them will probably be uh
caught before they land you know or
explode maybe they'll be neutralized
some way
another possibility is that you know you
have all these killer satellites out
there you kill the satellite then I
don't know if you can guide the missile
so yeah I don't think that uh if we
throw the nukes ever ever you know
um that we will kill everyone on Earth
no way but that's not the point the
point is if we do a lot of people will
survive but then the question is under
what conditions will they survive will
they survive in a way that they can live
forever or restart the race or whatever
or will that be just the beginning of
the end
and I uh will vote for the second option
I think that will be the beginning of
the end and again it's uh because more
than more than destroy people it will
destroy the global economy once you
destroy the global economy uh I don't
think you can restart it back again so
the nukes may be part of that process of
the global economic uh crash collapse
uh that's all I can tell you is from my
point of view and if that ever happens
yeah then uh I think we're scheduled for
extinction and if that ever happens I
think it'll happen before the year 2100
okay we're at 20 what 23. and so at most
I'd say we'd have 80 years to go I don't
even think we have that much I can't
tell you a date when it's going to
happen uh but the circumstances don't
look very good when you have some of the
experts like I said at the beginning
here uh predicting right
uh that things are going to get worse
that we're going to enter a period of
deflation uh including recession and
depression and possibly you know what
comes after depression well it's not
rebound it's Extinction
so keep that in mind that's what we
propose in this channel these are
theories here
okay let's let's move on to our steady
state what is a steady state and for
that we got to look at um
what I've been looking at lately and
that is what I call the universal movie
The Universal movie is a tool okay let's
get that straight uh people say well
what do we need it for et cetera et
cetera it's a tool
what's the tool for it's to be able to
stop the universe okay we want to stop
the universe
okay what do we mean by that well you
can imagine the universe being a flow
you know uh one location at a time and a
series of locations make motion even
time if you want to include the word
time in there but it makes motion so
what you have is a motion picture of the
universe every atom in the universe
moving from one location to the next
very slowly across the entire universe
okay that's that's the notion of the
universal movie and what we're saying
here
um when we're talking about
one frame of the movie we're only
talking about location a static concept
every single atom in the universe at one
distance from at a given distance
separation from all the others okay so
we freeze the universe at that frame and
we can analyze what exists because
whatever exists exists in that frame
okay including the invisible stuff that
we cannot see okay okay so here we have
the universal movie and here are some of
the typical uh static Concepts that we
need in order to provide physical
interpretations okay the main words okay
here here they are what is the word
object you need that in physics at least
distance separation between two objects
location which is the set of distances
and existence which is you know an
object that has location those are the
four primary ones but today we're going
to talk about uh steady state the other
day we covered the word State and we
said it's a static concept unfortunately
you know the mathematical world or a lot
of people out there just about everybody
out there thinks of State as something
in motion in other words you you say uh
for example that plasma what is plasma
well they defined it as the fourth state
of matter right but uh that state is in
motion because you can't have plasma
without ionization you need to have that
electron leave or come into an atom in
order for that atom to be ionized it's a
it's a pool of atoms and loose electrons
we go by the quantum mechanics version
of it and that soup we call that plasma
so it's not a state like a like a cross
section of time the famous state of
plasma is that things are in motion you
do not need that for solids liquids or
gases I can throw a liquid on the floor
like water or milk
and I can say that's a liquid and it
doesn't have to be moving for it to be a
liquid plasma does have to be moving so
we distinguish the notion of state of
physics from the notion of state of
mathematics okay but here we're talking
about steady state is steady a static
concept or is it a dynamic concept
that's the issue we want to look at
first okay
so let's look at that give me a second
here here we have it
steady you look it up and say and we
have like half and half sometimes it's a
static constant you know we have firmly
placed or fixed
well obviously that suggests a notion of
something that's not moving in fact it
says stable imposition or equilibrium
free from change
you know I think it's straightforward
steady means something static
no motion okay but look at the dynamic
uh aspects of the word steady even or
regular in movement
constant regular or habitual
okay and so yeah you have a regular
movement versus stable imposition so you
have one notion of the word steady which
is static and another one which is
dynamic okay so we have a little bit of
a contradiction uh in the way these
words are defined or used okay even if
they're not defined in a given way
that's how they're used they can be used
either way it's like you're covering
all bases you're covering the static
notion of steady and the dynamic one
here's the word State we we covered that
the other day but uh let's rub it in one
more time okay these are the Notions of
the word State and again you can see
that it's got two aspects to it one is
the static notion and the other one is
the dynamic notion the static concept
the condition of matter with respect to
structure form Constitution
well there you see a rock you know the
condition of matter like condition of a
structure or form you're talking about
something static you don't need to have
anything moving in there it's it's not
embodied in the word in the notion of
static and the other hand you have
Dynamic the Dynamics aspect aspect of it
it's also defined as a phase
and phase like the phases of the moon
you know you're talking about change in
there the word phase includes
you know the the notion of change but if
that doesn't do it then you see the
other two Notions there a particular
condition of mind or feeling
a condition of a person and I want you
to keep in your head you know the word
condition okay we're gonna look at that
word condition there because if you look
at condition of matter condition of
structure what's your static you don't
have anything that needs to be moving
but when you talk about a living entity
and you're talking about maybe how they
think their mind what's going the
processes right then you're talking
about the condition of the Mind well
mind is a dynamic concept it's thinking
ing thinking right so that's what mind
is it's a process
and so we have to distinguish how we use
this word state with respect to
something like a rock or something
inanimate right crystals
salt you know whatever you want to think
about and on the other hand a condition
of the mind of the person or the
feelings okay those are different states
so here we have two words steady and
state that's going to take us to the
theory of the steady state universe and
we have already some kind of
contradiction or you can say we we have
an oxymoron where we have embodied both
static as well as Dynamic Notions of
these words into one word in this case
two words one study in the other one
state okay and let's rub it in some more
just to make sure we drive home the
point okay here let me show you this
this is the word uh static that comes
from State static you know and this
static pertaining to or characterized by
a fixed or stationary what again
condition so we get back to the word
condition keep that one in mind showing
literal or no change a static concept
and they did put a static concept
someone was asking me hey Bill you know
we don't where did you get this notion
of a static concept well there you have
it I didn't invent that okay that that
was in the dictionary
lacking movement
and then as an example they have
electricity pertaining to what static
electricity you look up static
electricity and what does it say a
stationary electric charge built up
on an insulating material charge built
up so when you build you're now talking
about a static concept you're talking
about a process okay and then the last
one physics this is uh as the word
static pertains to physics acting by
mere weight without producing motion
static pressure
but pressure is motion
okay weight is a static concept
according to our site here okay not
according to mathematics but pressure
hopefully is uh you know pressure means
you're you're applying a force whether
you Triumph or not you're applying a
force and so they have all these
contradictions embodied in these static
Notions that we have of these words uh
State steady static in this case and
just in case I'm not done let's uh go
with one more and this is the word
stationary again all these words are
related you know stationary well you
would think it's a static concept right
a static concept why because standing
still not moving
what part did you not understand you
know it's it's static correct having a
fixed position again straightforward not
movable established in one place not
itinerant or migratory not changing
remain in the same condition or state we
get back to that word condition and you
can see we have a little different uh
there in the two examples there you have
standing still a ball just standing
still on the floor and then you have
same condition and you have the guy at
the hospital and he hasn't changed he's
in the same condition but we're talking
about an ongoing process of no change in
this in the in the condition of the
person
so we have these Notions embodied in you
know steady state static stationary okay
keep all those in mind and the keywords
I think or one of the keywords is
condition
okay so here let me move on here give me
a second here we have the word condition
what does condition mean here we have it
static concept existing state
now that's straightforward except that
we already said that state is defined as
both something in motion and you know
dynamic as well as static but here are
the dynamic Notions of the word
condition a particular mode of being
of a person or thing situation with
respect to circumstances fit or
requisite state to be in no condition to
run
okay that's not a static concept okay
that's an ongoing process knowing hey
I'm always the same I haven't changed
but I'm changing in the sense that I'm
looking at a movie and I'm saying I
haven't changed in any of the frames but
you need the movie for the word
condition under this notion of the word
condition a restricting limiting or
modifying what circumstance what is
circumstance well again it's a dynamic
concept okay and again I put the same
pictures there existing state for the
ball and mode of Being for the fellow
that is in the same condition hasn't
changed he's still in a comma but he's
still in the same condition but it's an
ongoing process
he hasn't died or whatever
okay uh here are some more words that
are going to affect us and again you're
gonna see how we mix these
Concepts
from the ordinary speech from the
dictionary how we use them in everyday
uh life and when we introduce them into
science into physics specifically and
you can see how they mess us all up
because people just extrapolate these
words directly into physics without any
scrutiny without analyzing what they're
saying okay and I'm going to be very
strict about this I want you to see uh
how I'm going to analyze these words
okay here it is here's the first one
continuous
versus constant okay now in ordinary
speech we say well continuous we can
apply to anything we say well continuous
is an adjective yeah correctly and uh it
is also in physics it's only an
adjective constant on the other hand
well we say it's a an adjective it's a
qualifier of a noun
not in science not in physics okay
constant can only be applied to motion
to verbs
okay you can talk about constant motion
you cannot talk about what constant
table
what do you mean by constant table
whoever said something like that well no
one does because it would make no sense
to say oh that's a constant table well
we can say it's Contin it's a continuous
table you know like it stretches from
here to there so we can use the word
continuous to um qualify a table a thing
an object but you cannot use the word
constant to qualify a noun you would
need to qualify a verb with that like
you know constantly uh moving you can
say I'm moving constantly that you can
say but we also say I'm moving
continuously
and that's where we make the error we
have to separate these words continuous
can only be used as an adjective in
physics constant or constantly as an
adverb can only be used with verbs
and we have a problem there because you
know uh relativity they talk about
moving uh continuously around the earth
you know not finding a a fence a wall
and so they say you constantly move
forever
eternally
um infinitely they use that word also
infinitely you know so keep those
Notions in mind because they do use
these terms to qualify uh a lot of the
Infinities of mathematics and they don't
even know what they're saying okay
because they you know the number line is
infinite right they say what do you mean
infinite well it means you can count
forever but then why did you use the
word infinite if infinite can only be
used as an adjective to qualify a noun
in physics meaning a thing and oh no
object is infinite because that means
it's growing forever and you can't see
the shape of that thing
okay so this is where the contradiction
comes in these words are key where
you're going to talk in physics that's
where the problem is
okay so yeah you cannot say continuous
Motion in physics you can say moving
constantly constant motion yeah you can
say that Eternal motion perpetual motion
you can say all of those but you cannot
say continuous motion because continuous
is a word that can only serve as an
adjective and can only be applied to
nouns what are nouns objects things
those are the only ones that can serve
as nouns and physics we do not say the
orbit of Jupiter that's an irrational
statement in physics in physics we say
Jupiter orbits the noun is Jupiter
orbits is a verb it's what it does we
don't turn or we don't turn verbs into
nouns we don't turn motion into objects
in physics not officially I mean you can
do it informally no problem because
we're all used to talking that way from
ordinary speech I'm saying we have to
keep track of what is the verb and what
is the noun in physics that's all I'm
saying okay so some people lose track of
that and they start talking about orbits
and they turn them what into
orbitals orbitals right what is an
orbital well it's what an electron does
does meaning verb around a nucleus
you see where the the contradictions
come in when they start putting these
words in the wrong places and people let
them go because they say well I heard
that in ordinary speech yeah but that in
physics you have to be uh you know you
have to be very concerned about someone
using those words in physics in the
wrong place
and uh here's the definition the
official definition continues okay and
let me put that over here
and here you can see it says continuous
uninterrupted what in time
what do you mean in time
they're talking about a movie and
they're saying it's the movie is
continuous in other words that it
doesn't stop
okay and they're talking about a verb
they're talking about motion they're
talking about time the seconds are are
streaming by right without cessation
continuous coughing
so when you cough continuously one right
after another they call that continuous
okay and then uh being in immediate
connection or spatial relationship and
there they give you two examples it
continuous series of blasts
a continuous row of warehouses okay so
one is in time and the other one is
spatial and the other one you know
connection time or motion and so we have
these uh where we merge continues uh the
uh application to verbs and we unite
that without any scrutiny without uh
indiscriminately to uh objects as well
okay and so and and there's and there's
an issue there especially with my friend
Aristotle because he talked about
continuous and the notion of continuous
of mathematics is exactly the opposite
of the notion of continuous in physics
if one number comes after another
Aristotle said well there continues you
know like one comes after another
and next to the other uh one right after
another in time in a space it wouldn't
matter what in all contexts one is right
after the other that's not the notion of
continuous of physics physics means made
of a single piece that's what continuous
means so when you point to a table
you're assuming it's continuous meaning
it's made of a single piece that's what
you mean by that okay and that's
different than the notion of mathematics
which is exactly the opposite which is
made of parts of segments of points and
one point is right after the other
okay one number right after another
Etc
okay so keep in mind the Notions these
Notions are have been uh misused they've
been misdefined to begin with okay and
uh so I'm trying to straighten the
language here okay
here's another famous word that uh they
use heavily in mathematics and physics
and I want to distinguish the notion of
physics from mathematics okay it's the
word straight
you know you have straight and you have
motion and you can't say I'm moving in a
straight line
no no that's an irrational statement in
physics you do not move in straight
whatever
it's called rectilinear
rectilinear motion straight uh ruler
maybe or whatever object now you see
straight ruler and you have rectangular
motion okay same applies to curve versus
curvilinear curve the banana is curved
okay for curvilinear is the motion of
something in a
curved manner okay so you got to look at
you know how something moves versus what
something is okay we don't say for
example we don't use straight as an
adverb we don't say oh that's straightly
no no we don't use that word doesn't
exist we say rectilinearly motion is
Right till dinner or he's moving
rectilinearly
okay so uh all these words we have to
clarify because they've been misused for
hundreds of years I like to emphasize
that we need to correct all this because
we talk with the wrong language and
people think they know what they're
saying and they do not because they
confuse nouns with verbs when they apply
adjectives to verbs and adverbs to nouns
okay that's where the problem is here's
another one how about bent
pending you know warped okay well I can
say a warped banana
because that's what an object is or you
can say a warped hammock okay you can
use it like that but where's the problem
the problem with relativity tells you
that uh light is Warped or light is bent
be light as bent what do you mean light
is Warped are you seeing the photon the
little no size Photon you bent it
and what they're talking about something
different they're talking about
deflection they deflected the photon in
in other words warp space-time assuming
we're going to assume for a second that
it's a trampoline Okay uh canvas okay so
it's warped okay no problem let's just
concede that so the the canvas is worked
and they see we worked light or we bent
light
no you did not bend light
the photon or a series of photons or
light was deflected Not Bent
okay and you see how they end up with
all these irrational statements this is
coming out of mainstream science and
nobody catches this stuff they say oh
yeah bent live we bent light with
gravity what do you mean you bent light
with gravity you could have been maybe
been uh maybe you know um the canvas uh
assuming space-time is a physical entity
let's concede that for a second okay so
we can bend the canvas but the photon is
rolling along or be or sliding along and
if it slides or rolls it's going to be
deflected Not Bent okay like a banana so
again all this pertains to the language
that these people use to convey their
physical interpretations okay so I'm not
out of line here okay anyone who wants
to criticize me well I've got my
baseball bat ready
okay here we have another one uh how
about the word line that we covered the
other day here we have line and a curve
right versus displacement and a geodetic
okay uh geodetic geodesic right you've
heard of those terms there you have
geodesic at the bottom uh right okay
it's a Kirby linear itinerary because a
geodesic is not a line in the it's not a
line period it's it what it is is an
itinerary a trajectory it's motion it's
a verb and people say well I traced the
line to represent
the geodesic yeah you may have I don't
care you know but what you're
representing is motion and people forget
about that and they say okay I forget
about motion what I see in front of me
now is a line so I'm going to be talking
geometry now you're not talking geometry
because geometry you have to start out
with a physical object you need a uh a
figure it's called a figure right Euclid
remember that so he called the figure
and I think it was a definition number
five what is a pink here well it's that
which has shape that's what a figure is
on the other hand you have curve there
you have it a warped stick in this case
a protractor okay so you can see that
it's curved okay so you can say that's
curved warped whatever word you want to
use but you cannot say a geodesic is
work it's called
deflected you're deflecting motion uh
you're deflecting whatever's moving
that's what I mean right okay
let's move on here here we have another
one another famous one the one I hate
the most and it's the word infinite okay
no such thing as infinite it's an
irrational term but what they're talking
about Perpetual or Eternal okay and
those can be applied to verbs because
they apply they relate to time what
they're saying is you can move forever
that's that's the notion they're talking
about but they say oh uh the the
who was it um uh Stephen Hawking is it
that the universe is finite but
unbounded
what do you mean finite
uh he meant that you know it's a an
object like all balls here here you see
a ball okay and that's finite you know
that you see the shape you see the ends
of it it doesn't grow or anything so you
see with the the perimeter you see the
the surface okay so we call that a
finite all objects are finite because
the word finite is a synonym of the word
object but there's no object that is
infinite so you cannot talk about
infinite object because what you're
saying is infinite finite meaning you
have an oxymoron built into that term so
infinite is an irrational term in
science we don't use the word infinite
but it's heavily used in mathematics why
because they're not talking about things
they're talking about counting they're
talking about numbers they say oh
infinite numbers or infinite series or
whatever infinite set
and here you have Perpetual okay there
you have the symbol at the bottom is
that infinite or Perpetual or what
should we call that well they they use
that symbol that uh uh lying down eight
and uh we say that's a sign of infinity
well the eight is finite as an object B
there's a shape in front of our eyes
Okay so that's a finite shape because
all shapes are fine motion around that
figure eight you can call that Perpetual
okay but not like uh Stephen Hawking
said unbounded meaning infinite
yeah but he meant to say is you can run
around the surface of in the in case
case he called the space time but we can
say around the surface of the Earth or
around the surface of the Moon it
wouldn't matter you can run around
forever that's not unbounded you don't
say unbounded to running he's using an
adjective to qualify a verb he's using
it as an adverb so he says finite bite
unbounded that's an irrational statement
it comes out of all these great people
you know from mathematics so keep all
that in mind
okay uh so why am I bringing all this up
what's the relevance all the of all this
okay let's let's apply it now okay we
have the wave function okay the quantum
wave function uh what was that do you
remember well if if you remember uh from
quantum mechanics from our great white
fathers they said that a particle is not
really a particle see we're not talking
about the particle that we used to have
in the days of Newton which was a
corpuscle that was a particle a real
particle a little ball looks like this
you know this this is a particle that's
what it looks like okay you can see it's
Finance Round great that's not a
particle of quantum mechanics so what is
a particle in quantum mechanics well
it's a wave function collapse
hey let me repeat that so wave function
collapse the wave function has collapsed
and turned into a particle it morphed
from verb to noun
yeah yeah just like you hear it more
from a verb to a noun and here's and
don't it's not me saying this okay here
here's from official sources okay before
you uh Lynch me okay here it is
encyclopedia of quantum physics and
philosophy of science collapse of the
wave function what is it collapse of the
wave function is the transformation from
a spread out wave function function is
what an equation to a localized particle
you've turned a bunch of numbers
a wave vectors remember uh magnitude and
Direction into a thing into a particle
okay why is it a particle is it because
you can see it it looks like a ball you
can draw it no it's a particle because
you can touch it
they suddenly sense something and
they're saying that the wave function of
that object which extends throughout the
Universe suddenly collapsed to a single
singular point
and because they were able to detect it
with you know usually with some
equipment uh now it's no longer a wave
function now it morphed into a what is
it particle
that's what it is
so and and that's what our great white
fathers uh told us to believe this their
physical interpretation and you say Bill
this is all your opinion we don't
believe in you okay great let's let's
bring all 30 to Bear here we have Mr
Heisenberg okay he says Heisenberg did
not try to specify exactly what the
collapse of the wave function meant
however he emphasized that it should not
be understood as a physical process
okay Niels Bohr also repeatedly
cautioned that we must give up a
pictorial representation and perhaps
also interpreted collapse as a formal
not physical process
okay so we're not talking about physics
here anymore we're talking about an
abstraction there you see the equation
that's a Schrodinger's equation okay and
so what are they talking about well
they're talking about the wave function
collapse what is that that means that
they took this uh spread out wave
whatever wave is and I've talked about
that in the past essentially wave uh is
a magnitude and Direction because all
it's a wave is built of um vectors
that's all a vector is magnitude and
Direction they represent it with a
little arrow an engine Arrow you know
they have all these engine arrows and
all that forms a wave and now they're
saying that's Wave It's Not only
stretches all the way to the edges of
space-time wherever that ends but
suddenly it collapses to a point as soon
as someone or the machine or a robot or
whoever touches whatever you need to
touch as soon as it senses something the
wave function collapses that's what a
point is
so a wave function is motion it's
Dynamic there is no physical Standalone
object static you know State steady
state you know called uh wave function
okay here's another one this is a an
even worse one this is the string string
of string theory you heard a string
theory okay here it is string a physical
entity This Is How They Define it a
physical entity postulated in string
theory physical entity okay okay so it's
a physical entity okay we all imagine it
more or less like this like a rubber
band you know there there you have a
string that's what it looks like that's
what you see there objectively on the
screen okay here it is in my hands okay
okay so you so now you know what a
string looks like it looks like a rubber
band a closed loop uh rubber band but it
says unlike Elementary particles which
are Zero Dimensional or point-like by
definition strings are one-dimensional
extended entities
okay one dimensional extended entities
fundamental entities are strings rather
than Point particles
okay we have a problem here because they
they say it's aligned okay it's it's a
line what was a line was aligned a
rectangle elongated rectangle no it's a
series of points which represent
locations meaning many locations meaning
we're talking about motion a string is
made of motion
so it's not a static object that you can
point to like you do there see I can
point to that object that's on the
screen they represent it as what a
two-dimensional because at least that's
got two dimensional maybe three but
never one so we're not talking about a
line or a geodesic here in the sense
that
um it's got at least two dimensions
what you're looking at objectively in
front of you is a thing that's not what
a string is a string is itinerary it's
it's motion
and it's Motion in a circle and then
they have this motion itself then it
moves back and forth because they turn
the motion the circular motion into a
rubber band now they're going to stretch
and you know deform the rubber band
that's string theory for you in a
nutshell okay so yeah what you're
staring at is not what you see is not
what you get okay that's that's
essentially the bottom line on that okay
and finally we get to our steady state
universe okay
here's the uh notion where we got this
okay it comes from Friedman 1922 can
introduce the idea of an expanding
universe that contained moving matter
correspondence with Einstein suggests
that Einstein was unwilling to accept
the idea of an evolving universe and
worked instead to modify his equations
to ensure a what static Eternal Universe
static Eternal universe as believed in
Newton's time okay so we had a little
Revolution there in 1922 where Einstein
was thinking of a static Universe an
eternal universe and Friedman says no no
we have an expanding universe some years
later in 1926 Hubble published the
redshift versus distance relationship
you know the Hubble law namely all the
galaxies in the neighborhood seem to be
receding at a rate proportional to their
distance and then we have our good
Belgian astronomer George's lamenter and
he said it may be noted that in 1927 he
also independently reads the conclusion
of an evolving universe
okay so it starts with this revolution
that occurred in the Roaring 20s where
people like Einstein were overthrown
and we're replacing this so-called
steady state you know an unchanging
Universe which is the one Newton had in
mind
and now we're gonna have this Dynamic
universe that is going to explode it's
going to expand remember the Big Bang
did not come really until the Matrix uh
suggested this right he suggested that
Hubble looked at the stars he said all
the galaxies are receding so from that
they put two and two together and they
said okay if we take all that back we
end up with a big bang and then idea
came a few years later but everybody
finally converged upon the idea that
there had been a big bang eventually
13.8 billion years ago and from that
Singularity that exploded that I guess
God made I don't know where it came from
nobody knows because we always start big
bang a friend number two in a universal
movie so from that explosion we have
this expanding universe
great
so what is the steady state well that
was proposed by people like Fred Hoyle
and uh bomb boom and here we have them
this is steady state Theory brushing
Fred Hoyle was a a proponent of steady
state and she said steady state Behavior
unchanging in time
well that sounds like static you know I
mean what are we talking about here
nothing changes is that what Einstein
was referring to is that what Fred Hoyle
was referring to now it says steady
state model of the cosmos okay and
listen carefully here it is the density
of matter in the expanding Universe in
the expanding Universe remains unchanged
due to a continuous creation
of matter
okay we're talking about the creation of
matter the constant creation of matter
that's the steady state
steady you know not not meaning
something without Motion state meaning
something not without motion we're
talking about creation of matter but
it's a continuous and they use that word
again continuous uh creation of matter
so he's saying that density remains
always the same
and that contrast to The Big Bang Theory
which says look as time goes by there's
uh there's lower density of matter in
other words as matter expands you know
uh the uh you can say the bundle of
matter in the universe becomes uh less
dense that's the notion that they have
what's the coral area there's the
observable universe is practically the
same at any time in any place
so these two uh people really have the
the
um same notion in a way except that they
differ how much density there is the
official version is that as time goes by
density goes uh the lower so there's
less density over time and the steady
state says no the density is always the
same the universe always looks the same
regardless of when you are born in in
throughout this expansion right but
because matters constantly being created
from the void which in a way is
supported by quantum mechanics because
quantum mechanics talks about particles
you know
popping in from the void you know this
um
you have the positive and the negative
they break up because when they they're
together they form space when they break
up they form particles which are
detected in our world uh so called the
virtual particle and quickly recombines
and goes back to being nothing magic
great stuff you know if you're into
magic it's great if you're into science
it's terrible
and so here we have it okay here's the
image of what a steady state is versus
the big bang here you have them okay the
steady state cosmology matter is
constantly created as the universe
expands so I have no idea what they mean
by Universe are they talking about space
are they talking about matter exploding
like a hand grenade are they talking
about both
and then you have the big bang cosmology
matter dilutes as the universe expands
again what do you mean by Universe are
you talking about space are you talking
about matter are you talking about space
and matter
you see these people never clarify what
the word Universe means what do you mean
does Universe expands see they could
have easily said matter dilutes as space
expands right so we can say okay space
is getting bigger right and matter is
always the same so there's uh less
density of matter that we can all
understand but when they say that the
Universe expands in the case of big bang
cosmology there what you're saying is
that the expansion of not the universe
of space is pushing the particles apart
and they call that whole thing you know
the Big Bang explosion whatever they
don't like the word explosion either but
it says matter dilutes as the universe
expands so they they're talking about
space and matter because universe is
space and matter
but steady state as you can see it's uh
in contrast to that is that it's um it
maintains the same density because
matter is being created from the void
okay but if it's being created what is
this nonsense about using the word
steady and state if study and state are
both static Concepts but they've turned
them into Dynamic Concepts so both
steady and state are Dynamic and what
they're talking about is constantly
expanding and it's a miracle they didn't
use the word continuously instead of
constantly because again they would be
committing another crime by using you
know continuous
okay so you got it we got to have uh the
language straight if you do not have the
language straight you are not giving a
rational physical interpretation which
is what these people are not giving you
and you have to be careful with all
those words and challenge them at each
one of those words because they are
misused because they are misdefined
because they are defined both as static
and as Dynamic Concepts therefore people
say oh I understood all that and they
didn't understand Squad because they
were not paying attention to the words
that the mathematicians are are using to
convey their physical interpretations
okay okay let's move to our science
critic and this fellow talked about
predictions okay and let's find out what
he's got to say let me uh first say the
following he's uh he believes that
predictions are part of the scientific
method
and here as you know we say that
predictions have absolutely nothing to
do with the scientific method uh
scientists are not astrologers or Palm
readers you know we don't do that kind
of work it's not in our it's not in our
job description okay so we don't do
predictions so how did predictions
become part of the scientific method
what is the notion that these people
have where did they get these ideas okay
so let me put them on this is going to
be uh
uh that are science critic and let me
give me a second here
okay and here goes listen carefully uh
to what we're trying to figure out here
here goes
be issue to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
our predictions are part of science
our predictions are part of Science and
clearly they are a part of science if
someone says you're going to get a phone
call within four minutes and you get a
phone call within four minutes then you
might assume that they have some kind of
knowledge as to why you're getting the
phone call yes it could be a lucky guess
but the more information they provide
about it the more likely they have some
knowledge like if they say oh Tom is
going to ring you in four minutes and
then Tom does ring you in four minutes
that is very unlikely that they just
guessed that however if someone says
you're going to get a phone call next
year and you do get a phone call next
year then it doesn't take a genius to
work out that likelihood was that you
were just going to get a phone call
regardless of whether they knew anything
about it or not
okay so what's the issue there okay uh
where do we start there's so many things
wrong with what he said and again it's
because they have this notion that
astrology is part of science okay that
they do predictions in science we don't
do those we don't do prophecy uh palm
reading none of those things in science
so uh you can see his notion of it he
says you know if you receive a call
within four minutes after the prediction
uh looks like he knew something but if
you receive a call next year anytime
during the year he says that's not a
prediction because more than likely you
would have received one anyways okay
these are the Notions these people have
where do we start well we start how
predictions enter the scientific method
and where do you think they came from
well they came from math
okay they didn't come from physics they
came from mathematics here it is okay a
prediction without more these are my
statements okay prediction without more
is just a description that's all
prediction is you haven't explained
anything all you know if you say there's
gonna be an eclipse tomorrow at two
o'clock and it happens so far you
haven't explained why or you know how
come all you told me is what's going to
happen that's only a description so far
all you get is a description if the
astrologer can explain okay explain
right the cause that underlies uh what
is going to happen then he has no choice
but to draw upon his experience when you
explain something like if you can
explain why the cause
the mechanism that causes an eclipse
then you're not talking about the future
now you're talking about the past you're
not making a prediction now you're
explaining what uh something from your
experience you've already had some
exposure
to whatever whatever happened so if you
know something about
um eclipses okay and one example that
comes to mind okay is uh uh what is this
in uh Connecticut Yankee in King
Arthur's Court and that was a book by uh
Mark Twain
and he's got this uh one of the first
guys who talked about time travel by the
way in fact it probably is the first
book I don't know but he goes into the
past this Connecticut Yankee he goes
into the best and he knows that on such
and such state
there's got to be an eclipse
and he knows why because the moon is
going to interfere between the uh Sun
and the Earth
and so you know the people in those days
they have no idea what causes eclipses
and he already predicts it he says look
in the next few minutes there could be
an eclipse and all the people go oh
he knows why because he knows that at
that moment in time there was going to
be a moon moving between the Sun and the
Earth and why because he went to the
Past you got to travel to the Past in
order to explain okay you have to have
some experience with with eclipses for
example right and so it says experience
passed and explain you can only explain
what a consummated event
okay science is about explaining about
the past only we have to explain in
science how did something happen by what
mechanism that's what science is but to
describe and says there's going to be an
eclipse tomorrow two o'clock and you
don't say more than that you haven't
explained anything all you did was give
a description and that's all a
prediction is without more okay without
more if you can explain what's going to
happen Ah that's a different story
because now you're talking about the
explanation and now about the prediction
okay explanation of a prediction is
different than the prediction which is
just a description that's what I'm
saying here okay here we have uh here
you have an example okay mathematics
describes physics explains you see uh
Magician on stage he cuts the lady in
half
okay so you ask the mathematician next
to you hey what happened uh how did that
happen he said well look uh uh here we
have uh x equals a B plus C where a is
the head B is the Torso and C is the
legs uh the guy used 20 Strokes of the
saw 10 seconds cut it in two pieces
curtains closed curtains open and the
lady comes out alive
that's a mathematician talking
now here's the physicist talking here's
a scientist okay
he wants to know how the trick was done
you know how did the magician do the
trick so here's three theories the first
one body is under the stage you see the
picture there okay the body of the girl
is under the stage Theory number two two
girls in the Box there's two boxes one
girl's in one box the other one the
other you can see the head of one and
the shoes of the the legs of the other
so that's another way of doing the trick
that's another theory that physicists
might propose here's another theory one
girl under the other okay so you can see
that one's under the stage and so you
cut only up to the stage so you're not
cutting the girl it's just the position
of the girls how they how they tricked
you so these are the mechanisms these
are the causes this is how he did the
trick but to say that the magician just
uh saw the girl in 20 Strokes in 10
seconds in two pieces you know that's
not science that's just what happened on
stage
so we we have to distinguish a
description from an explanation and a
prediction is nothing but a description
okay
so here we have it okay
math can only describe math has no power
or authority to explain you know if I
tell you that this pencil falls to the
floor at 9.8 meters per second Square
I'm giving you an explanation I just
tell you that's what's going to happen
it's going to fall in a tenth of a
second or whatever I can tell you all
that yeah you can do that but what you
cannot tell me yet with mathematics
right you cannot tell me what caused it
to go to the floor was it some particles
pushing the pencil downwards was it some
something pulling it from the earth from
the center of the Earth that's that's an
explanation I want to know the mechanism
that's physics it is thus that science
has become a synonym of math
okay because that's all that math can do
the mathematicians are the ones who took
over physics they call themselves
mathematical
quotations on this physicists right and
so they're all they're doing is math
they're doing equations they're
describing things and no more and then
they give you the most irrational
physical interpretation they can come up
with you know work space that's why the
pencil felt on the floor right and so
science has become a discipline that is
identified with description meaning what
prediction
genuine science is explanation
okay
so that's the starting point I'll
continue with uh or fellow here uh
science critic uh next time
okay let's continue here with the fan
mail I received a couple letters here
let me go through them first guy says if
a hypothesis cannot be tested it's a
belief
a belief is not science your belief may
be very irrational and logical makes
perfect sense and obey the Occam's razor
right but it's still a belief if you
can't prove it look at the words he's
using right if I claim unicorns or God
exist and I provide no evidence
whatsoever is that science to you
I don't care for technology but I want
to accept just any hypothesis without
something to verify it a hypothesis
without any observation is useless
science is falsifiable you know Mr Carl
popper and that has been proven
throughout history
man he's got so many things wrong I
don't even know where to start I have no
idea where to start he's got so many
things just wrong you know completely
wrong and why because he's got this
notion of the scientific method that
they fed to him in high school or
college or wherever
we don't test hypothesis because
hypothesis are assumptions
in fact we don't test anything in
science because testing means I'm going
to run some kind of experiment okay to
prove he talked about proof there
why so that I make you believe like you
like I believe I want you to think like
me so I'm going to convince you I want
to pursue you I want to recruit you into
my religion
so I say look let me prove it to you let
me prove that God exists let me prove
that this table exists let me prove uh
how gravity works or whatever
so I'm gonna prove to you
why because I want to convince you I
want to persuade you we don't do that in
science in science we don't persuade we
don't convince we don't recruit we don't
convert what we do in science is explain
so that the other person understands the
mechanism we propose whether he believes
it it's none of our business that's that
doesn't concern science that concerns
religion
you know uh he goes to his dark basement
he wants to run an experiment that's his
problem we don't care when he comes to
the conference we want him to explain
the mechanism he proposes
so that's one issue the other one is
that he says he's going to try to prove
something exists through some kind of
experiment okay let's take God you want
to take unicorn if that's less violent
okay let's use the Unicorn
I want to prove a unicorn exists how do
I prove it uh should I bring the unicorn
in here by the horn
you know just drag him in here and say
look I'm going to prove to you that
unicorns exist what I do you get a horse
and put a uh a little cap you know
appointed cap in his head then it's a
unicorn
how do I prove God do I bring God here
next to me and say look this is God
folks here you see him you can touch
them is that how we prove God
so how do we prove the Rope hypothesis
the assumption that everything is
mediated light is mediated by ropes and
gravity as well
if I'm telling you in your face that
it's intangible and invisible
uh what kind of experiment do you expect
me to run take you to the lab and see
and touch it am I supposed to see and
touch the what is invisible and
intangible
why do you think that Quantum cannot
figure out all uh the how this universe
works at the micro level right because
they can't see or touch the mediators
so what what is the point of running an
experiment if I cannot see or touch
which is what a lab is for
okay and then falsifiable there you know
what are we talking about we're talking
about again uh Carl popper says you know
falsifiability
what is that that means I'm going to
falsify meaning I'm going to prove you
wrong
you don't believe change your belief
that's all it is and observation well
how do you observe that which is
invisible I mean I can't observe the air
and if you want to include touch in
there no problem uh you know I I can
touch the air but I cannot touch other
things that are objects like you cannot
touch the table that I'm thinking of
right now
hopefully the word table always
represents an object I'm thinking of a
table can you touch the table I'm
thinking of
can you touch the table the Klingon is
sitting on or or eating on right now on
the other side of the universe
you know so not everything can we see or
touch
so not everything can be tested through
an experiment but even if we could
that does not uh prove its existence
because I prove it to you I prove it to
you and to the pope okay Pope Frankie my
my friend so I go and prove to the Pope
that this chair exists
because he can see it and touch it how
about the other eight billion people on
Earth am I going to go to every one of
them and say look let me prove to you
that the table exists
hopefully the table exists before I can
prove it to anyone
and so there you realize that you need
to define the word exist and not prove
it like this fellow's suggesting through
some kind of experiment some kind of lab
or whatever
okay next issue here if I'll says uh
related to the Rope model okay here he
says I I still don't understand
aggregation
okay good question can you explain it
again I understand what you are saying
about see and touch okay but I can't
imagine how the rose aggregate uh to
create tangibility
okay would they pass right through each
other can you draw a picture
uh-huh
well the question is valid it's a very
important question lots of people wonder
about these things okay when I bring up
the Rope model the first thing I want to
clarify that it's not the rope that uh
produces aggregation
it's the thread people confuse the rope
with the thread and the thread with the
Rope so I I always try to clarify that
not everybody captures that thought okay
so we're not talking yeah the ropes can
go through each other yes they do
because Mother Nature doesn't uh you
doesn't have the power of touch
for these intangible invisible entities
it has no ability a rope has no ability
to touch another one okay and before you
can talk about touch you have to Define
what touch is
and uh touch means that two objects
become one they fuse and become one
that's what touch is touch is zero
distance
okay I'm the guy who defined that uh you
can look it up in my book okay touches
zero distance touch means that two
objects become one so when you put your
thumb against the table you can press
down as hard as you want you never touch
the table in physics in ordinary speech
Yes but not not in physics in physics
touch means that your finger became
part of the same object as the table
that's what it means they fuse to become
one a single object okay so let's make
sure we understand the difference
between ordinary speech touch and
science touch science we have to Define
our words a lot more carefully pay
attention to language okay so that's the
first thing I want to clarify now he
asks okay how does Mother Nature produce
touch because obviously obviously right
an atom touches another atom they bounce
they you know they bounce away they hit
each other you know they Clash against
each other like you know I can't go
through the uh through the table or
through the chair
as soon as I hit the chair I I feel my
uh pain in my knee okay so I cannot
avoid that and you say well why didn't
my my knee go through the chair or
through the table why couldn't I do that
when does Mother Nature produce touch if
everything is made of the thread
that's the question we're trying to
answer here okay how do we produce that
magic
okay so let me give you a magic trick
here okay this is the magic trick I'm
gonna do in front of you you saw it here
first let me remove this for a second
here
okay magic trick okay
we have two magnets
you see nothing and you touch nothing in
between them
well my fingers cannot touch or see you
know or my eyes can't see what's between
these two magnets
but apparently one magnet recognizes the
other one because you can see as they
get together it immediately sucks it in
they touch each other they they
recognize touch but I can't I can't see
or touch what's in between
and so people conclude well there's
nothing in between can't be because I
can't see or touch it
while you see one magnet recognizes that
there is something between because it
one affects the other
and if you say and listen carefully now
if you say there's nothing in between
there that one magnet attracts the other
without anything being between them you
are doing this explanation with black
magic
we don't do black magic in science
Mother Nature doesn't do black magic God
doesn't do black magic the devil doesn't
do magic black magic and neither does
Father Universe none of them do black
magic so whoever you believe in whoever
you pray to I don't care they don't do
black magic every one of these things
has some mediator that we cannot see or
touch the problem is in the definition
of what an object is what a thing is a
thing is not that which you can see or
touch which is our notion of ordinary
speech a thing is that which has shape
there's something that has shape here
but you cannot see or touch it we when
we come to grips with that with that
notion where those definitions the whole
thing changes now you can now you have
the eyes of God now you can see that
which you cannot see
that which is invisible there's an
object here that has shape I'm saying it
looks more or less like a rope and when
the ropes are untangled it looks like a
threat okay so here we have some
touching going on one magnet is touching
the other it with some invisible entity
in there that touches each other
so what is my uh Theory again it's a
theory I'm going to make the assumption
that there are threads moving at Great
speeds hundreds of threads moving at
Great speeds between those two magnets
okay so they're moving in the same
direction let me do it here okay like
that as one comes up the other one comes
down they attract each other that's what
attraction is repulsion you turn one of
the magnets around you have North
against North or South again south now
the threads go Clash against each other
and they push the magnets away okay the
theory is clear it's very simple baby
stuff 10 year old can understand it
so when does touch I mean if one thread
can go through another thread we say
that's intangibility when threat cannot
touch another thread but what happens
when you have gazillions of thread
moving in Direction like in the case of
uh repulsion well now you have
aggregation it's by aggregation that
mother nature produces touch
and it's only one example let me give
you another example the other example is
that a um a
an atom you know the the electron is a
shell it's a membrane weaved
by all by countless threats threads
arriving from every rope in the universe
electromagnetic rope in the universe all
the ropes converge Upon Our atom and one
of the threads goes around and forms the
electron shell
meaning shell a real shell not the one
in quantum mechanics which is an energy
level or a orbital where you can find
the electron bead which is not a bead
which is what a wave function collapse
et cetera et cetera Etc no none of that
now we're talking about a membrane
but now what do you have you have you've
weaved the electron with countless
threads now you approach tangibility
because you have aggregation
and a fellow asked me to illustrate it
here it is okay here's the atom first
okay this is weaving of the electron
shell okay I want you to see this okay
we're weaving there you see the electron
shell being weaved
by gazillions of thread just think of
unimaginable number of threads okay
coming from every atom in the universe
so now you can have now you have a
surface
you have a surface now you can talk
about a surface of the electron of the
atom hitting another atom now you have
touch you have Collision now you don't
have intangibility anymore now you have
now you bump your knee against the chair
and it hurts okay that's what you see
there okay now you have the other one
the one for the magnets okay let me show
you this okay this is the best picture
I've got made by my son by the way one
of them
and um you can see countless threads
moving around okay so you have
tangibility only because you and I have
drawn every thread by the way but
imagine gazillions of threads just
moving around and that's what produces
tangibility aggregation of threads you
have walls of threads only then can you
talk about tangibility until that
happens a rope going through another
rope uh thread going through another
thread hey that's a piece of cake for
mother nature she she could do that
easily she does it every day okay
so uh I hope I answered the question
there and the last one here we have the
line okay well it says line elevated
rectangle right yeah that's what I say
it is that's all you see in front of you
it says rectangle equals what
oh we got a problem I mean what do you
see in front of you what is objectively
in front of you
uh don't you see an elongated rectangle
unless my eyes are failing me I mean
that's what I see in front of me it's a
red
elongated rectangle it's two-dimensional
it's got a width and it's got height
that's what you see in front of you and
we're going to talk about length as
being the perpendicular to both those
directions
so what you have is width and height
it's a rectangle it's got straight edges
four straight edges two on the top and
two on I mean two on the sides one on
the top one on the bottom right that's
what you that's what's objectively in
front of you that's an elongated
rectangle
and you say yeah but that's not the line
of geometry that's not the line of
mathematics
well the line of mathematics is not
objective what you see is not what you
get they point to a stick like that one
and they say that's an itinerary it's
made of points what are points locations
or numbers and what are those those are
that depicts motion so they're not
talking about a line a one-dimensional
line they're talking about motion and
they call that one-dimensional motion
when the word Dimension can only be used
can only be used with objects only
objects have Dimensions
three-dimensional you know you can't say
running has dimensions what's the
dimension of running what is it length
width or height
you see the problem so I don't know what
this question is he says rectangle is
what well rectangle is the rectangle you
know it's a it's a plane and what you
see in front of you is a plane that is a
plane a two an elongated plane sorry but
that's what it is that's what's
objectively in front of your eyes
so uh I don't know clarify your question
next time though because what you see in
front of you is what you get that is
what a line is for the purposes of
physics and the coral area is we have no
use for lines in physics no use
whatsoever for lines or points or uh any
of those uh ideal geometric figures we
have no use for them uh we do things
with real objects
with that I'll see you next Sunday we'll
see you then bye-bye